in this video we're going to talk about
something called kinetic molecular
theory which sounds very fancy but as
we'll see in the next few seconds or the
next few minutes it actually helps build
our intuition for what is actually going
on with the gas or at least an
approximation of what's going on with
the gas so first let's think about the
types of things that we know we can
measure about a gas at a macro level now
what do i mean at a macro i'm saying at
a large scale at a scale that's much
larger than the scale of atoms or
molecules and we know the types of
things that we can measure we can
measure pressure
how do we do that well pressure is just
force per unit area so you can do this
there's various contraptions you can use
to measure pressure depending what
you're using it for force you can
measure with springs and you can apply
certain forces to certain square areas
but these are all ways that you can
measure pressure and we can measure the
pressure of a gas in a container you can
measure volume
of a container that's actually pretty
straightforward you can imagine a
container that looks something like this
it's volume we know how to find the
volume of a rectangular prism like this
or even if it was a sphere or some other
type of figure there's many ways of
measuring the volume without even being
able to observe or even know that things
like molecules exist
we know how to measure
temperature
and we can do that in different scales
kelvin is what we use because it's more
of an absolute scale but you can use
literally thermometers to measure
temperature and once again you can
measure temperature without knowing
anything about atoms or molecules or
whether they even exist and you can also
measure an amount
an amount of a substance and in
particular we could say you can measure
the number of moles now you might say
don't moles involve a certain number of
a molecule or an atom
well they do but the notion of a mole
actually existed even before we knew
exactly how many molecules how many
particles made up a mole it was just
viewed as an amount where people knew it
must be some number of particles but
they didn't know exactly so all of these
things we can measure at a macro level
and we know that we can connect them all
with the ideal gas equation that tells
us that pressure
times volume
is equal to
the amount of the gas we're dealing with
and this is of course we're talking
about an ideal gas and in future videos
we'll talk about how
some gases approach being an ideal gas
while some are less than ideal
but the amount we have measures number
of moles you have your ideal gas
constant that just helps us make all the
units work out depending on our units
for everything else and then you have
your temperature measured in kelvin and
scientists long before we were actually
able to know about things like atoms or
even observe atoms or molecules directly
or even indirectly they were able to
establish this relationship using these
macro measurements
but how do these macro measurements in
this relationship actually makes sense
at a molecular level and that's what
kinetic molecular theory provides us
it says imagine the gas as being made up
of a bunch of really really small
particles those are really the gas
molecules
and their collective volume is very
small compared to the volume of the
container so it's mostly empty space
between those particles
now the pressure is caused by these
particles bouncing into the sides of the
container because at any given moment
you have enough particles bouncing off
the side of any unit area that it's
providing a force per unit area it's
providing a pressure it assumes that
those collisions are what's known as
elastic which you'll study in much more
detail in a physics course but it really
says that your kinetic energy is
preserved you might already be familiar
with the notion that kinetic energy is
equal to one-half times mass times
velocity squared and so the kinetic
energy of these particles when they
bounce off their mass doesn't change the
mass of the particle's still there and
we're saying that the velocity is going
to be preserved so you have all these
really small particles even their
collective volume is small compared to
the volume of the container they're
providing the pressure by having these
elastic collisions with the side of the
container and temperature is related to
the average kinetic energy of these
particles it would be proportional the
higher the temperature the higher
average kinetic energy now average
kinetic energy is really important
because some of these particles might be
moving faster than others and of course
n the number of moles tells us how many
particles we're dealing with we know
that each mole has avogadro's number of
particles so if you just multiply the
moles times avogadro's number you have
the number of particles and what's cool
about kinetic molecular theory i know
it's billed as a theory but this is
fundamentally what chemists and
physicists visualize when they imagine a
gas in a container of some kind and just
to make it a little bit more clear the
axioms you could say of kinetic
molecular theory the assumptions of it
i'll give them here if it's important to
realize that these are assumptions and
the real world we have slight variations
from it but these assumptions get us a
long way to explaining the behaviors of
gases so we've already talked about a
gas consists of particles in constant
random motion we've already talked about
that they're bouncing off the side of
the container the combined volume of the
particles is negligible compared to the
total volume in which the gas is
contained and that also matters when you
talk about things like ideal gases
because if it stops becoming negligible
then you have to start thinking about
the repulsive and attractive
interactions a little bit more
the particles exert no attractive or
repulsive forces on each other and that
kind of builds into the last point i
just made which is if they did then
we're getting closer to being a less
than ideal gas and we'll talk about that
in other videos the collisions between
the particles are completely elastic so
they preserve kinetic energy and it's
actually they would also preserve
momentum and that the average kinetic
energy of the particles is proportional
to the kelvin temperature and we already
talked about that that the macro
variable the macro measurement of
temperature is giving us an indication
it's proportional to the average kinetic
energy of the particles